on ne veut pas se retrouver devant métro
est heureux
12h22 tu as raison c'est un calleur
l'enterrement
j'ai aucune envie d'y aller mais
personne n'a envie d'y aller bonjour
maman qui revient qui est encore chez
mais là c'est un fils pierre
heureusement qu'elle à votre femme
mon ex femme a oui c'est bien triste ça
aussi bon qu'à la dynamite ailleurs je
voudrais mourir à sa juliette je sais
que c'était peut-être importants que
pourrait penser voilà peut-être convient
de mieux tout de suite si ok d'accord
c'est mon laisser tomber fêterai mes
pauses et quand même votre grand mère
est sortie de chez elle plusieurs fois
plusieurs nuits bon c'est quoi l'idée
voulait la mettre dans une maison dieu
c'est non
si tu as tout ça va quand même ça va pas
être facile tous les jours parce qu'ils
sont pas tous partout c'est un bon choix
pardon eh ben on pourrait la prendre à
tour de rôle chine où je peux les bonnes
idées du tout quoi ça sert tu étais
comme ça et je m'entête parce que
j'aurais adoré commerçante être pour moi
dragons en famille tu vois bien que les
enfants j'ai un peu merdé je les aimais
beaucoup mes soeurs quand j'étais petit
j'avais l'été à saint junien
j'ai l'impression qu'on est tous
éparpillés moi j'ai besoin qu'on se
rassemble près 30 hier pour être calme
n'empêche quand on s'intéresse à la
découpe mais je m'intéresse à elle
qu'est ce que tu veux chose de plus tu
fait ses courses toutes les semaines je
lui fais livrer son repas le midi tu fis
là tu fais comme tu as toujours fui
d'ailleurs je sais que c'est pas facile
pour toi mais j'aimerais bien que tu me
reconnaissent
de l'enfant je me souviens que de ce
chien tu te rappelles je sers comme on
attendait ça
m
on n'aura pas tout watts et finalement
non pas tout
ciao
que
[Musique]